what's going on guys today we're going
to be breaking down these spoilers for
my academia chapter 323 and judging from
these leaks so far it kind of puts nezu
back in the uh traitor frame for me like
before i wasn't really sure about him
being the traitor i thought it might be
aoyama or invisible girl but after this
chapter i'm starting to reconsider a
little bit because it seems like he
knows more about shiguraki than he's
revealed in the past and tokiyami even
calls him out on that in this chapter
before we get into the details though be
sure to hit that sub button if you
haven't already and drop a like as it
does help out the channel
okay so the title of this chapter is
called one step and it begins with a
flashback of the students at the
principal's office just before they
started searching the streets to try and
find deku eda remembers what the
principal said about showing everyone
how great the ua barrier really is and
tenu believed that if they could bring
midoriya back peacefully the barrier
strength would be enough to calm the
civilians down in the flashback though
nesu disagreed with that opinion saying
the issue is bigger than just this
according to the principle midoriya is
the hero's trump card so keeping him
sheltered without proper security would
pose a big risk to everyone he compares
the level of security at uwa to that of
tartarus prison which as we all know was
totally destroyed by the villains not
that long ago but he goes on to say that
after the school gate was decayed by
shiguraki way back at the beginning of
the year he's worked hard to try and
improve their defenses since then the ua
barrier has now been reinforced and it's
not only a barrier now but instead is
able to actually move the school
underground the campus itself has been
divided into several areas all of which
are connected to something described as
a motorized elevator-like device and if
any sign of invasion is detected all of
those areas will transport to the
underground shelter from there the
school can follow various different
underground routes with kaminari saying
that this sounds like something straight
out of a robot anime i gotta say this is
a pretty big development i mean the fact
the whole school can be taken
underground i mean kind of reminds me
something from like uh i don't know it's
a mixture of the matrix and also that
movie when like the cities were like
moving i guess like a combination of
those two um but as kaminary says i'm
sure there's a specific anime that i'm
not remembering or that i don't know
about that this was inspired by the
underground area around uwa is also
being protected by 3 000 layers of
fortified metal plates and if any of
those plates detect something wrong the
system would activate and presumably
take the school underground in addition
the plates have to hold back any
villains trying to attack giving these
students and the civilians time to get
to the underground shelter other hero
schools have also reinforced their
security like this and they are also
connected to these underground routes
shiketsu high being one of them that
part was actually mentioned in the last
chapter as well i can't remember if it
was kaminari again but someone mentioned
how the ua barrier connected shigesu
high so oh it was sarah i think i'm
pretty sure it was cerro actually um so
yeah i guess this is what they meant you
know connect literally connected
underground like i guess they could move
towards each other and merge if possible
like i guess that is possible now um but
yeah that is interesting there's like a
whole underground system that we never
knew about until now on the topic of the
3000 metal plates um so the panels
aren't out yet so i don't know exactly
what this looks like but the way it's
described is kind of like there's a
plate a plate a plate a plate like that
kind of thing so they're not touching
each other that's what i'm that's what
i'm visualizing in my head because when
we move on to what tokyo is about to say
it makes it seem like this is
specifically designed to deal with
shigeraki's decay quirk as i just said
though the panels haven't leaked for the
specific plates that he's talking about
so i don't know what it looks like this
is just me guessing but when the full
chapter comes out then i guess we'll
know anyway tokyo army comments that
these metal plates seem specifically
designed to deal with shigeraki's
awakened decay quirk which spreads to
other surfaces he asked why the
principal had already set up this plan
even before the cultural festival when
there was no such available information
about the villain's quirk that right
there is a very valid line of
questioning because at the time of the
cultural festival shiguraki's quirk uh i
mean it was fairly normal he hadn't
upgraded it to the level of uh
maybelline academia yet so how would
nezu know to upgrade the system in this
specific way to counter his awakened
decay quirk for me it kind of implies
that maybe nezu knows more about
shiguraki than he's revealed in the past
when it comes to nezu potentially being
the traitor i think there are three
things we need to remember number one is
that you know shigaraki's awakened the
cake work it was actually just his
original decay quirk like when he was a
kid it was on that same level of power
so anyone who knew shigaraki as a child
or knew all for one when chicago was a
kid they would also know the power the
full power of decay so if nezu was
somehow acquainted with off one back in
the day then of course he would make
these adjustments because he knew the
power of decay like he knew his full
potential the second thing worth
pointing out is that back during the uh
battle training exercise in season two i
think it was recovery girl she said that
nezu was experimented on by humans and
that he has a sadistic side sometimes so
basically nezu was experimented on and
he has a grudge against humans so
sometimes he lets that come out so to me
if he is the traitor maybe it's possible
he has two sides to his personality like
literally a split personality um and i
guess one side he has the uh you know
the regular principal nezu that we know
and then the other side is this evil
person potentially that is secretly
giving the vin's information and i guess
you know the good side wins most of the
time but sometimes the bad side comes
out i don't know exactly but i feel like
that could be a thing the third thing we
need to realize is that everything we're
seeing right now is the culmination of
like years and years of work by afo i
mean if if we just go back the higher
nomu that was that was something that
appeared in vigilantes around six or
seven years before it first appeared in
the minor academia anime shirakuma was
another example you know he's had
shirakuma for 15 years as a nomu then it
only gets revealed recently in anime
like all this stuff has been afos
planned for so long so i think the idea
of him tinkering with nezu back in the
day 20 years ago 15 years ago and then
now you know nezu being the traitor
that's entirely plausible as well
because of one has been setting this
stuff up for years for years so right
now nezu looking real sus i think it
could be him i really do um
him between him and aoyama right now in
my head
but it always changes every every time
there's new information it always
changes but uh yeah let's let's continue
nezu answers tokiyami's line of
questioning by saying that he just
followed his instincts even without
concrete evidence he says that even
something incomprehensible or
unnecessary can be the missing step to
reaching the end of a challenging path
chapter 323 then cuts back to the
present with the civilians refusing to
let deku in and midoriya's mother and a
few others like cote and eri are all
shown to be very concerned number 13
mentions that some people were convinced
by the principles guarantee of their
safety but obviously not everyone
because i mean as we can see a lot of
people they're scared that by bringing
deku in they just might get killed in
the crossfire like if the villains come
up to deku they're probably going to get
injured as well right best genius then
shows up and interrupts president mike
who in the last chapter was trying to
calm everyone down and the number three
hero explains to everyone that they
already tried to use deku to attract
shigeraki and it didn't work he then
says that even though deku is shiggy's
target he is also the hero's greatest
weapon so although the current situation
isn't ideal the best alternative is to
let midoriya stay at ua until he's ready
to fight again the civilians then seem
to get even angrier because of this
saying that the country is only in chaos
because the heroes failed and now having
failed again they want to force
civilians to take the risk as they're
yelling at the heroes deku's danger
sense activates but before anything can
happen to him ochako grabs present
mike's microphone and uses her quirk to
float herself on top of yuey's rooftop
she begins her speech by confirming that
deku does indeed have a special power i
mean i guess everyone knows it at this
point but still you don't need to just
blurt it out to everyone it was meant to
be a secret but uh anyway the civilians
reply by saying that is exactly why he
can't stay there but ochako replies by
saying this is what midoriya himself was
thinking as we saw he tried to stay away
and all his classmates basically needed
to force him to come back
she continues her speech asking the
civilians to take a good look at how
deku looks right now after holding this
burden all by himself there are some
panels emphasizing his claw-like hands
and feet and some civilians are shocked
by looking at him ochako says that deku
is the one who wants to change the
current situation the most and that he
kept moving forward for other people's
sake even though he could have been
attacked at any moment that much is
definitely true because he was attacked
by so many different villains even ones
that we didn't see uh because as we
remember you know that panel with all
the villains that all for one enlisted
well yeah we didn't get to see all those
guys we saw dictator we saw um who was
that guy there but besides that there
were not too many ones that we saw the
spoilers then go on to say that the
giant woman who deku saved in chapter
310 then appears and she recognizes him
uraraka continues shouting saying that
having a special power doesn't make deku
a special person bakugo then appears by
midoriya's side saying that civilians
desperately rioting while ignoring the
security system is a perfect example of
something deku can't handle by himself
and he needs to leave it to the others
the chapter then cuts to an internal
monologue from nezu acknowledging that
the first step is always hard however he
thinks that this step specifically will
lead to the birth of a hero who
surpasses even all might the chapter
then comes to an end with the last panel
being ochako screaming in the rain and
um yeah that's the end of it i mean it's
pretty good i guess the main purpose of
this chapter was to explain how the ua
barrier is going to work because we all
know they can't mention the underground
thing and not go underground like they
will definitely be going on the ground
at some point um and also on top of that
in my opinion it plans to seize fenesse
being the traitor because the way
tokyomi was like
questioning him you know the way tokyomi
was like bro how do you how do you know
how to do this
you didn't need to put that in there he
didn't need to write that um i kind of
feel like maybe that's hinting at
something but we will see uh but let me
know in the comments what you think of
this chapter and also what you think
about nezu maybe being the traitor do
you think it's him do you think it's
ariana let me know in the comments down
below and until the next one peace out